tania vincent ledoux monsieur le premier
ministre
j'associe mon collègue bernard gérard
monsieur promise dans la nuit de samedi
à dimanche le personnel urgentistes du
centre hospitalier de tourcoing a été
agressé par une quinzaine d'individus de
la même famille accompagnant leur père
victime d'un malaise
les personnels comme les patients
décrivent une scène d'une brutale
sauvagerie avec mes collègues maires
gérald darmanin et marie tonnerre nous
sommes allés à leur rencontre hier pour
signifier notre solidarité nous avons vu
des personnels de boue tous ont repris
leur poste le lendemain malgré les
blessures et les traumatismes hommage
leur soit rendue mais c'est personnel le
ch le premier ministre ont peur
terriblement peur
leur mission exige pourtant la
préservation d'un environnement
professionnel de qualité car les gestes
qu'ils posent sont des gestes de secours
et de vie vous rendez vous compte mes
chers collègues au moment même où des
médecins se trouvait confrontée aux
coups violents d'agresseurs sans foi ni
loi
d'autres dans les mêmes lieux un tube et
un patient dont le pronostic vital
nécessité un dialogue intime avec la
famille pour envisager un don d'organes
comment soigner sauver des vies
accueillir les souffrants dans de telles
conditions
médecins et infirmiers ont peur et
attendent réparation mais ils craignent
qu'une fois encore l'impunité prévalent
sur la sanction
interpellé et présenté hier en
comparution immédiate
les trois agresseurs les plus violents
ont obtenu un report d'audience
choqués les victimes devront attendre
trois longues semaines dans l'espoir que
justice leur soit rendue mais pire
à peine remis en liberté les agresseurs
dont certains sont bien connus des
services de police
continuez de me lasser leurs victimes
jusqu'au sein même du tribunal pour en
irait-il autrement dans cette drôle de
société qui ne prive pas immédiatement
de liberté ce qui frappe nos l'est et
insulte nos médecins que faut-il de plus
la justice et la liberté en ex krivets
joubert aujourd'hui notre justice tient
davantage de la remise en liberté en
action alors monsieur le premier
ministre pour éviter que cette violence
ne soit qu'une statistique de plus
qu'envisagé vous de faire pour protéger
réellement celles et ceux qui pensent
nous plait mr et sony
la parole est à madame marisol touraine
mai
des affaires sociales et de la santé
ainsi monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
le doubs dans la nuit vous l'avez dit du
15 au 16 octobre dernier des faits d'une
violence incroyable se sont produits à
l'hôpital de tourcoing incroyable parce
qu'il n'est pas acceptable est pas
tolérable que des professionnels
soignants médecins infirmières et des
personnels administratifs soient prises
à partie et soit l'objet d' attaques
violentes
un médecin a été frappé ses cheveux
arrachés
une infirmière a été plaqué au sol je
veux rendre hommage le aux promoteurs de
santé du service d'urgence 2 pourquoi et
à l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
des hôpitaux de france qui sont parfois
amenés à rencontrer des scènes d'une
grande violence
je veux également salué les forces de
l'ordre qui sont intervenues très
rapidement et ont permis l'arrestation
de trois individus avec bernard
cazeneuve
nous avons travaillé à la mise en place
d'un plan d'action qui s'applique à
l'ensemble des établissements
hospitaliers
depuis plusieurs années des conventions
entre les établissements hospitaliers
les services de police et les services
de justice sont signés il bouclait en
mentionnant que la police dans des
délais rapides
au-delà de cela et en lien étroit avec
l'ensemble des fédérations hospitalières
j'ai annoncé il y à une quinzaine de
jours environ
un certain nombre de mesures qui font
par ailleurs l'objet de financements
importants d'abord des plans de
sécurisation de l'ensemble des hôpitaux
sont réalisés
éolien avec les forces de l'ordre
ensuite des moyens financiers sont
apportées pour la mise en place de
moyens de protection et de sécurisation
et je le redis monsieur le député dans
la sphère de tourcoing je souhaite que
des sanctions exemplaires soit appliquée
pour que de manière fort qu il va être
envoyé un message vous semble la parole
est à mme